so just announced at this event date
when you saw about Tim Cook talked about
the iPad pro that iPad pro interesting
borrows a lot of the innovations that
came from the Microsoft Surface which is
to say it's got a keyboard if you want
it also has a stylus
so the Apple pen exclamation points if
you care to but it is a bigger iPad
indeed the iPad air which was their sort
of top-of-the-line up until today if you
turn that on its side the height of the
iPad air is the width of the new iPad
pro which is twelve point nine inches
measured diagonally so that's a big
thing we're also the new chip in it the
iPad the a9x
which they say is 1.8 times faster so
it's significantly faster than their
last chip it's thinner it's bigger it's
got a keyboard it's got a stylus also
announcing some minor tweaks to their
watch law and introducing some new new
colors a a rose aluminum rose gold
aluminum which is a aluminum but colored
with sort of a sort of a red or gold
color perhaps an emphasis on the cheaper
models not their fancy $10,000 actual
gold edition watch and some new bands
including a band from ermes should you
choose to wrap your wrists in leather
with a watch if you choose a wrapper
with wrists and leather otherwise that's
certainly a choice one can make
especially here in this great city of
San Francisco but that's far kind of
while they're calling them monster
announcements mark thus far kind of
things that we expected from Apple and
important things that they needed to do
to try to get extend these brands get
people buying particularly iPad which
has seen at least six quarters of
declining sales going into the most
recent quarter a brand they need to
revive I'm sure Corey as aside from all
of these things that we're hearing out
of Apple what do you think investors
want to hear from Tim Cook today well I
think one of the things we'll be
listening for is not just what the
products our but where they're going to
be released are they going to for
example launch this and these new
watches globally or are they going to
start just in the US suggesting that
they've got supply issues helping us
understand helping investors understand
what this might mean for q4 sales or at
calendar q4 sales apples quarter of
course ends and
September so the release dates are
important they said the new watch 2.0
software will be available starting
September 19th globally the the watch
the new watch is available actually
today in Apple stores so the rollout
dates are important the rollout
geography is important because at that
point the analyst can start to pencil
out she they've got these new products
might add to sales in these geographies
times whatever that's actually might
give you your your actual projections
for sales interestingly despite the
pullback in the in in the Chinese
economy the devaluation of the yuan
analyst expect the 23 percent growth
rates a little bit slower but
nonetheless 23 percent sales growth rate
they've raised their estimates since
July of Apple sales for the fourth
quarter calendar quarter so we'll be
looking for reasons for that from
today's announcement acorrea have to ask
you quickly in advance yeah I have to
ask you quickly in about 20 seconds Tim
Cook's been doing this for a couple of
years now is is he now is he now owning
this event the way that Steve Jobs used
to I don't think any one event like
Steve Jobs did and I think we remember
that even more fondly as time passes but
Tim Cook you know this is his company
he's mastered the supply and demand
parts of this company the inspiration
part of this company he's trying to do
that right now but you know Matt
Miller's was say I'm not really selling
it I'm not a Salesman Tim Cook he's the
salesman the lousy apple press that's
and they're tweeting like crazy
exclamation points they're the sales
people me I'm just gonna tell you what's
happening let somebody else sell it
you're just our humble journalist Corey
Johnson under editor at large companies
from outside the Apple event in San
Francisco